bon allez c'est le premier jour de la
visite donc du roi Charles
III pour l'occasion d'envoyer donc le
plus grand expert de la monarchie
britannique Bertrand Decker je sais pas
où il est actuellement il me dit qu'ils
ont duplex apparemment
juste tu es magnifique mais tu as le
temps tordu
elle ne traverse
c'est parce que ce fut compliqué Cyril
compliqué d'arriver
alors là tu es où là
militaire on est dans la cour on est
très exactement dans la cour royale du
château de Versailles c'est ici
précisément Cyril qu'à 19h55 la Citroën
qui va véhiculer Brigitte et Emmanuel
Macron va se stationner sur le tapis
rouge que vous pouvez voir derrière moi
et 5 minutes plus tard
c'est que nous on va arriver en Citroën
et eux ils vont arriver
disons que vous mettez la France à le
nord et les mettre l'Angleterre d'accord
sinon qu'est-ce que tu as nous dire
le château de Versailles sont très très
haute sécurité Cyril j'ai couvert
quelques voyages d'État quand même c'est
pas le premier je vous assure que c'est
la toute première fois que je vois ça
c'est à dire qu'il nous a fallu plus
d'une heure pour pouvoir accéder dans ce
périmètre ici que vous voyez réservé à
la presse on a eu des maîtres chiens on
a eu des déminards on a eu une fouille
au corps bref on château et sont très
très haute sécurité pourquoi parce que
le roi la reine le couple présidentiel
certes mais de stars
on a déjà
pas vraiment on a plutôt aperçu Mick
Jagger qui vient de remonter là le tapis
rouge on attend Hugh Grant et judo
arriver dans quelques instants on a vu
Bernard Arnault absolument oui tous les
tous tous les grands noms en tout cas de
l'industrie et du sport le sport Cyril
sera également excuse-moi puisque Amélie
Mauresmo excuse-moi juste tu as envie de
gagner Wimbledon ben je connais Amélie
moresmo c'est la directrice du tournoi
de Roland-Garros
Didier Drogba vient aussi d'arriver en
fait tu dis des noms tu sais pas du tout
qui sont les gens que tu annonces
moi aussi je peux dire il y a Bernard
Fourcade
très très grands noms et on le rappelle
180 convives seulement vont pouvoir
prendre place Cyril ce soir dans la
galerie des Glaces les 60 et toi
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire pendant que
pendant qu'il mange tu vas faire quoi
toi
je vais attendre je vais attendre tu vas
pas manger avec eux
[Musique]
le palais de l'Élysée vous savez il y a
eu un bras de fer je voulais expliquer
entre petit cam et le palais de l'Élysée
il a fait que 60 invitations à pouvoir
distribuer et bien un seul journaliste
de Royal très très connu sera à la table
voilà
il s'appelle le Stéphane Stéphane
quelque chose
c'est pas bien évidemment pour France
Télévision qui a été retenu oui
à table du roi commencez une seule table
a été dressée pour que tout un
commentaire sonne à la table tu crois
est un summer
tu as le seum et cette table Cyril fera
62 mètres de long ce que je t'ai parlé
de la table
pardon mais j'avoue que j'entends
difficilement bah dis-leur d'arrêter
derrière la musique là
la musique derrière
dès lors on s'entend pas on est en
direct
qu'est-ce qui sont en train de jouer là
ils sont basés ce sont des musiques
militaires
il y a des beaux gosses il y a des beaux
gosses
tu sais il y a une très belle assemblée
on a surtout vu des dames très très
élégantes à des beaux gosses oui il y a
des beaux gosses il y a des belles meufs
aussi parce que on rappelle que ce soir
la tenue obligatoire
[Musique]
bon la tenue obligatoire Cyril c'est
smoking pour les hommes et robe longue
pour les dames par contre toi durant un
serveur
[Musique]
franchement ça te va hyper bien et puis
on avait personne d'autre quoi ça te va
bien franchement ça te va bien
tu vas pécho tu penses là-bas
je te tiens au courant en tout cas
dans 2 secondes c'est bien qu'ils ont
arrêté de jouer là dis-le merci
dis-leur merci
[Rires]
thank you peut-être on va crier Cyril on
criera en l'honneur du roi alors je suis
content que tu as eu la créditation
quand même et que tu es content d'être
là-bas tu te rends compte c'est un peu
ton rêve tu vas voir le roi tu vas le
voir passer devant toi
il va il va être ici à quelques mètres
je suis incapable de vous dire qui c'est
en tout cas Cyril le défi pour ses dames
je vous assure c'est de marcher
correctement
il y a des comme un peu il y a des beaux
gosses lui j'aime bien avec les dossiers
et tout devant lui son instinct bon
Benaim
c'est le restaurant
comme ça lunette et tout quoi qu'est-ce
qu'il y a c'est qui le gars avec les
dossiers là il y a un prof de maths ou
quoi là
c'est un des responsables presque pour
le coup du Palais de l'Élysée
tu peux lui dire
il est beau gosse moi j'espère surtout
pouvoir tenir encore jusque l'arrivée du
roi il me reste 35 minutes encore si je
pouvais éviter d'être évacué entre temps
[Applaudissements]
on te rappelle on te rappelle alors le
roi bon il est arrivé en France là il
est arrivé il était Camilla on sait sa
poule
il est arrivé au salon
autour de 14h en ligne il est très sympa
il a foutu un bordel c'est Elisabeth
borne qui est allé chercher elle a pris
l'Opel Corsa
alors d'ailleurs grosse surprise parce
qu'il va arriver à la gare du Nord mais
parce qu'il était écolo et tout par
hasard là le problème c'est que c'est
infréquentable et il pouvait pas tout
nettoyer la garde du Nord tellement
c'est un bouge bon vous dire il a même
plus aller même pas pu prendre le train
même le roi il peut pas prendre le train
ok Elisabeth borne elle attendait sur la
piste d'atterrissage donc il croyait
qu'il croyait au départ il croyait que
c'était l'hôtesse de l'air il dit oui
donnez-moi des cacahuètes un
peu tard justement
il est rapidement monté à bord de la
Bentley royale la Bentley elle est
royale
la première c'est cette histoire là eh
c'est beau mais c'est moi qui conduit
j'ai l'impression
gars regardez
[Applaudissements]
alors et ouais donc on a on n'a pas des
vidéos parce que les photos c'est sympa
on n'a pas les vidéos ah bah voilà
de descendre cette passerelle la
compagnie de la reine Kamila un petit
peu devant à Orly actuellement il faut
tenir les chapeaux par le 3 souriant
voilà qui sert la main à la première
ministre
limousine avec le drapeau royal alors
que le couple royal est en train de
monter à l'intérieur c'est une voiture
très particulière
et tu as vu que la robe de s'envole pas
malgré le ventre parce que c'est depuis
Elisabeth II toutes les femmes de la
royauté pour éviter des photos un peu
incongrues etc elle on leur cou un petit
peu de plomb long ça tienne je croyais
mettez des Polaris
on voit que c'est le roi et la reine on
voit que c'est pas c'est pas Gilles
Verdez qui arrive avec Daniel et il
aurait pu l'attendre dans l'escalier
Cyril quand même
elle a eu du mal qu'elle avait son sac
le chapeau
Nice et se bat
[Rires]
après ils se sont rendus vers 14h45 à
l'Arc de Triomphe ils ont ravivé la
flamme du soldat inconnu et c'est ils
ont retrouvé Brigitte Emmanuel Macron
donc ils sont appelés on se retrouve à
quelle heure alors bah ouais bah vas-y
sur les champs allez vas-y ok ok et là
ils sont tout bloqué je vous explique
voilà je suis actuellement j'étais dans
le quartier bah j'ai pas pu passer rien
du tout tu es peux même pas accéder à
une personne
et même le métro était fermé les métros
s'arrêter et tout tout tout tout ils ont
tout bloqué
regardez donc il était à l'Arc de
Triomphe
le 3 qui est arrivé à l'instant qui est
salué par le couple présidentiel entre
donc les deux chefs d'État toujours au
salut à la symbolique de la manière dont
on salue Charles et Camille alas
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait Brigitte Macron
est-ce que c'est comment dire
conforme ce qui est attendu il y a pas
eu de révérence particulière une poignée
de main c'est la modernité
c'est pas mal hein
il a un truc je commence à le kiffer
j'aime bien est-ce qu'il a j'aime bien
il a un délire comment ça je trouve
qu'il est un peu Cosmo bah des mieux
maintenant
Emmanuel Macron bah c'est pas pareil
des pieds couvert d'oignon et personne
c'est un peu fait parler aussi parce que
brise Macron a fait la bise en fait à
kamia et moi elle aurait dû faire la
révérence royale et lui elle lui a
claqué la vie Bertrand Decker tiens qui
savent pas à rien
dis-moi juste elle a fait la bise à
camélia enfin comment elle s'appelle un
Camila
on aurait est-ce que c'est pas le
protocole Cyril aurait plutôt attendu
une référence de la part de la première
dame en effet vis-à-vis de la reine on
rappelle que c'est la première fois
Cyril qui viennent en France depuis
qu'ils sont rois et reine sinon c'est le
35e déplacement officiel parce que je
voulais vous dire aussi parce que j'ai
suivi les manifestations de tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il y a déjà eu entorse
au programme puisque le roi a déjà
réalisé deux badfull alors que ça
n'était absolument pas prévu non c'est à
dire qu'ils sont à peine arrivé au pied
de l'Arc de Triomphe il y avait des gens
qui acclamaient le roi vive le Roi vive
le Roi et alors il a été vers la foule
et lui-même a été parlé a été parlé aux
gens scènes qui s'est réitérées à
l'issue à la sortie du palais de
l'Élysée lorsqu'ils ont lorsqu'ils sont
remontés pardon la rue du Faubourg
Saint-Honoré pour rejoindre l'ambassade
de Grande-Bretagne
la fameuse Bentley devrait quitter
l'ambassade qu'est-ce qu'ils vont manger
du pénis
étoilé puisque
il devrait passer à table au coup de
20h30 d'abord commencer par elle doit
avoir la dalle le prince là
le roi il a la dalle non
a prévu chez Martin en entrée du homard
bleu avec du tourteau servir sous en
voile d'amandes c'est ensuite Yannick
Alleno qui prendra la suite avec de la
poule de Brest pochée au champagne il y
aura en plateau de fromage puisqu'on
sait que le roi adore le fromage avec du
stickleton qui est en fromage
typiquement typiquement anglais
et donc
qui a été mis à l'honneur par un maître
fromager c'est pas Bernard Anthony et le
c'est absolument c'est Bernard j'adore
ce fromage février de France dis-moi le
fromage c'est pas du tout dis-moi le
fromage c'est pas du comté de 30 mois
ils ont dit je crois une bûche de chèvre
et un style tonne
c'est 100%
anglais tu es sûr
oui oui mais c'est le menu donc le Sea
shoton c'est 100% anglais et dis-moi il
y aura pas une gelée à base de
mirabelles on m'avait dit ça moi
lors du mais je vois que tu es très très
bien informé absolument le plateau de
fromage
de mirabelles et sur ils m'ont pas
menti et dis-moi il y aura pas on va
parler d'un Nice d'un Nice parent là en
dessert
pierre
à revisiter vous savez le fameux biscuit
de macaron
je peux te poser une question on me dit
il paraît que c'est une info à prendre
bien sûr avec des pincettes aux
conditionnel on me dit qu'il y aurait un
sorbet de litchi
non c'est chaud ou pas
de litchi et de rose
elle a été revisitée on m'a dit qu'il y
avait un macaron rose tu es au courant
ce qui est drôle dans ce qui est drôle
Cyril dans ce dessert c'est que
l'assiette va être bleue c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela une bleue bleu et
blanche il a été fait avec cuisiné avec
non mais des framboises particulièrement
mûres puisqu'elles vont donner sur le
rouge ce qui veut donc faire que
visuellement on aura bleu blanc rouge ah
ouais et ça ça fait marrer tout le monde
ça ça fait marrer tout le monde ça
donc là les gars ce soir
bon on va te retrouver dans un instant
la liste ouais mais 2 minutes il arrive
dans combien de temps là
il sera précisément le couple
présidentiel 19h55 le roi et la reine va
tort quelle heure
20h dis-leur qui vient avant
dis-leur qui vient avant je peux tenter
[Musique]
est-ce que tu peux nous chanter un petit
coup de Aptoide
encore 20 petites minutes
allez à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]